Okay ja.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Gürbüz. Ich bin Assistenzer Synthetik in der Notaufnahme.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Gechiffrefführen. Ist das für Sie in Ordnung?
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Okay. Kursum ablauf.
Du erst verdicht ein Parfraguz, der iral-person ist.
Dann komm ich sofort zu Iran ab und du fällst den Becher. Okay?
Okay, ja.
Und wie heißt es?
Ich heiße Hella Mager.
Könnten Sie bitte vor und nach Namen buchen, tabiere?
Ja, der Vorname ist H-E-L-A.
Hella.
Und der Familienname ist Mager M-A-G-E-R.
Okay, Frau Mager.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 62.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 8.07.60.
Okay. Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ja, auf dem Ausfall steht 1.67.
Und ich wiege so 78 kg.
Okay, was für Bischwärten haben Sie, Frau Mager?
Ja, Frau, Doktor, mir ist so schwindelig und mir ist so schlecht.
Und das geht jetzt schon eine ganze Weile so.
Ich habe das gefühlt, ich könnte jeden Moment umfallen.
Und das ist, wie aus dem Nichts, ist das gekommen.
Und ich kann das überhaupt nicht erklären.
Das ist in letzter Zeit schon häufiger mal so gewesen.
Das hat vor drei Jahren angefangen, da war das mal so hin und wieder.
Ich weiß nicht, wenn man sich gebückt hat und wieder aufgestanden ist.
Dass einem so schwarz wurde vor den Augen.
Und in der letzten Woche war das denn schon häufiger.
Und jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, dass es mir wirklich schlecht geht.
Und dass ich mich kaum noch gerade halten kann.
Also ich muss mich wirklich hinsetzen.
Okay, ich verschte.
Ich muss mich festhalten.
Ja, ich verschte Frau Mager.
Könnt ihr bitte general die Schminde, die Attacke, die Stühle, wie lange dauert die Schminde, die Attacke?
Also jetzt hat das ungefähr vor einer Stunde angefangen.
Und dauert immer noch an.
Und normalerweise ist es so nach einer knappen Stunde wieder vorbei.
Aber jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, ich kann überhaupt nicht gerade gucken.
Und eben ich muss mich festhalten.
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, als ob ich betrunken wäre, so als ob ich mein Schiffenstand habe.
Haben Sie das Gefühl, dass Sie im Boot sind?
So ungefähr, ja.
Ja, also ob ich will, aber auf einem stark schaukelnden Schiff, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Sie haben schon erwähnt, seit einer Woche sind die Schwindelattacke immer schlimmer geworden.
Ja.
Und heute, wie oft haben Sie in der letzten Woche die Schwindelattacke haben?
Da kam das zu jedem zweiten Tag.
Jeden zweiten Tag.
Und jede Attacke dauert ungefähr eine Stunde?
Ja, aber das geht ja nicht an, dass man aufhören, ja.
Das muss ja mal irgendwie in den Griff zu kriegen sein.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und ist Ihnen ein Auslöse erinnerlich?
Ich meinte, Schittres oder Bewegung, oder Aufschittieren, oder Nargikveranstaltungen?
Jetzt ist das eigentlich so ein bisschen aus heiteren Hummel, dass ich, ja, als ob ich betrunk wäre, ohne etwas getrunken zu haben, so ungefähr.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Verschlimmert sich die Schwindelattacke, wenn Sie bücken oder wenn Sie im liegen, umdrehen oder kopperigen.
Also bücken tue ich mich gar nicht im Augenblick, das würde ich mir gar nicht trauen, weil ich das Gefühl hatte, ich würde sofort umfallen.
Und ja, so im Bett habe ich schon auch das, wenn ich mich jetzt hinlegen würde, dreht es eigentlich weiter, ja.
Also okay, aber nicht verschlimmert.
Nee, verschlimmert nicht.
Okay.
Also die Schwindelattacke sind unabhängig von Koppbewegung.
Ja, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ich meine vor drei Jahren war ich mal bei meinem Hausarzt, der hat dann festgestellt, dass ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe.
Und dann hat er mir auch Medikamente verschrieben, die nehme ich auch ganz regelmäßig.
Aber deswegen ist das ja immer noch genauso schlimm und jetzt ist es eben gerade ganz toll.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Können Sie Iran-Hoch Blutdruck selbst messen zu Hause?
Ja, ich habe wohl so ein Gerät, aber ich benutze das nicht regelmäßig.
Okay, besuchen Sie Iran-Hoch als Regelmesch, aber stimmt?
Ja, klar.
Immer wenn ich neue Medikamente brauche, gehe ich dahin und also einmal im Jahr, dann misst er auch den Blutdruck oder so.
Okay, ist Ihr Blutdruck gut eingebaut?
Ja, ich weiß.
Eigentlich war er jetzt immer so okay, aber ein bisschen schwankt er auch.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Frau Marga, haben Sie Hörminderung oder Ohrsausen?
Ohrsausen habe ich nicht, nee.
Hören Sie gut als sonst?
Ja, eigentlich kann ich ganz gut hören, ja.
Zumindest, was ich hören will.
Okay, ja, ich verstehe.
Ist Ihnen Sehstörung aufgefallen?
Nee, richtige Sehstörung eigentlich nicht, das ist mehr ebenso dieses Schwindelgefühl.
Aber ich habe jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass ich vor den Augen irgendwas habe oder so.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Hm, Kopfschmerzen.
Dieses Schwindelgefühl macht mir schon auf Kopfschmerzen.
Oder vielleicht sind auch erst die Kopfschmerzen da und dann der Schwindel.
Das weiß ich gar nicht so genau, aber das tritt eigentlich schon zusammen auf, ja.
Und ich glaube, diese Kopfschmerzen sind insbesondere dann, wenn es auch, wenn so viel los ist, wenn ich Stress habe, ja.
Okay, also seit einer Woche sind die Kopfschmerzen schlimmer, oder?
Die sind eigentlich ziemlich stabil, die sind immer mal so anschlugsweise, ja.
Okay, also die Kopfschmerzen sind stressabhängig.
Ja, so ein bisschen, ja.
Ich verstehe.
Ist das übel?
Richtig, schlecht, nein, eben nur übel durch dieses Gefühl, nicht festen Boden unter den Füßen zu haben.
Aber ich muss mich jetzt nicht übergeben oder so.
Ich verstehe.
Okay, haben Sie noch andere Bischewarten, Frau Maga?
Schlafstuhlungen oder beim Stuhlgang oder Masalassen, haben Sie Probleme?
Ja, also mit dem Stuhlgang, da muss ich schon hin und wieder mal nachhelfen, ich leide unter Verstopfung.
Seit wann haben Sie Verstopfung?
Ja, auch schon ein paar Jahre, ja, vielleicht fünf, sechs Jahre, vielleicht auch länger, ja.
Dann nehme ich mal ein bisschen so spezielle Lebensmittel, die ich weiß, dass die gut abführen,
oder nehme mal ein bisschen leinsamen oder so was, ne?
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie in der Leistesartgewicht ab oder zu genaue?
Nein, das habe ich eigentlich, das ist immer stabil, wäre nett, wenn es mal ein bisschen weniger wäre, aber abgenommen habe ich nicht, nein.
Fühlen Sie sich müde?
Müde fühle ich mich schon ein bisschen, ja, ja, müde und schlapp und so, ja, ja, das würde ich schon sagen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Frau Maga, haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihr Hautblass ist?
Ihr Haut?
Meine Hautblass, aufgefallen, ich mir das nicht, aber jetzt ist ja auch Sommer, jetzt hat man ja eigentlich so eine gewisse Grundfreunde, ne?
Das ist man eigentlich nicht Blass.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Kraftminderung in Armen oder in Beinen?
Ein bisschen schlapp fühle ich mich und ich würde jetzt also eben unter dieser Schwindelattacke, würde ich mich jetzt nicht trauen, irgendwie schwerkörperlich etwas zu arbeiten,
weil ich das Gefühl hätte, ich würde etwas umschmeißen oder ich würde selber umfallen oder so.
Aber die Kraft ist eigentlich grundsätzlich in den Armen und Beinen schon da.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen, Herzstorben?
Beim Herz ist mir eigentlich nichts aufgefallen, nein.
Okay, fühlen Sie sich fieblich?
Fieblich fühle ich mich auch nicht nahe.
Okay, ich verstehe Frau Maga.
Ich habe einige Fragen, so Ihrer Vorerkrankung.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, seit drei Jahren leiden Sie unter an Bluthoffdürük, haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, ich nehme auch sonst keine weiteren Medikamente außer neben meinen Bluthoff-Tabletten.
Okay, welche Tablete nehmen Sie ein?
Ich nehme Belog Zock, das ist so eine 1.00, das ist so eine 47,5 Milligramm.
Und dann nehme ich noch am Lodipin 5 morgens eine.
Okay, Frau Maga, wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein, operiert bin ich noch nie.
Okay, das ist gut.
Bekommst Sie Ihre Regelberufe, Sie sind schon in den letzten Jahren?
Sie suchen Sie Iran-Franards regelmäßig?
Ja, zur Kontrolle, zur Krebskontrolle gehe ich da regelmäßig.
Okay, das ist sehr gut.
Und haben Sie allergin oder unverträglichkeiten gegen etwas?
Nein, zum Glück kann ich alles vertragen, ich habe überhaupt keine Allergien.
Okay, das ist sehr gut.
Und lauchen Sie?
Nicht mehr, ich habe vor fünf Jahren mit dem Rauchen aufgehört, davor habe ich aller den,
viele Jahre, ich habe gerade so ein halbes Päckchen am Tag, was halt so bei der Arbeit ging,
ja über viele, viele Jahre mit, dann habe ich dann angefangen, also es waren bestimmt 35 Jahre,
die ich geraucht habe.
Aber ich bin sehr stolz, dass ich seit fünf Jahren nicht mehr rauch.
Okay, 35 Jahre haben Sie geraucht.
Ja.
Ja, das ist sehr gut, dass Sie aufgehört haben.
Und ja, ich verstehe, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol, ich trinke mal eine Flasche Bier, jetzt gerade wenn es so warm ist,
abends dann mal so ein bisschen.
Jeden Abend, meinen Sie?
Ja, dreimal, viermal in der Woche, so wie es gerade kommt.
Framaga, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Ich? Nein, nein, also wirklich nicht.
Ja, sehr gut, wie gesagt, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Und Framaga, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Leben Sie mit Ihrem Mann?
Ja, ja, sicher, klar.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, wir sind Kinderlos.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ja, ich bin vielerischerweise, ich bin Zugbegleiterin bei der Deutschen Bahn
und habe natürlich ganz anstrengende Schichtdienste
und bin den ganzen Tag auf den Beinen.
Und im Augenblick sind die Züge alle übermäßig voll,
das ist alles furchtbar anstrengend.
Und da haben wir im Augenblick gerade richtig viel Stress,
zumal immer viel verspätung sind, die Leute sind sauer,
wollen ihre Maske nicht tragen, ja, da macht man schon was mit, sage ich Ihnen.
Ja, ich verstehe, das ist sehr anstrengend für Sie, genau.
Und eben immer andere Arbeitszeiten, ne?
Ja, stimmt, wir haben recht.
Immer Schichtdienst und jede Woche anders und so, ne?
Ja, sehr missam und anstrengend, genau, Sie haben recht.
Und Frau Maga, Leben Sie Ihrer Eltern, ne?
Meine Eltern sind beide verstorben, mein Vater,
der hatte vor fünf Jahren Schlaganfall und ist da dran gestorben
und meine Mutter ist kurz da drauf verstorben.
Keiner weiß so richtig, was der gefehlt hat.
Vielleicht war sie dann einfach alleine und wollte nicht mehr alleine leben.
Jedenfalls die ist auch vor fünf Jahren verstorben,
aber krank war sie eigentlich nicht.
Also, wie sagt Sie, woran ist die verstorben?
Man hat das nicht nachgeforscht, also, ne?
Die war halt auch schon 82 Jahre alt, da hat man, wie sagt es wahrscheinlich,
Herzschwäche oder irgendwas, keine Ahnung.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und haben Sie Geschwister Frau Maga?
Ja, einen Bruder habe ich.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, nicht wirklich, ja.
Das war auch der Grund, das habe ich mit dem Raufen auch gehört.
Dem hat man nämlich vor ein paar Jahren Unterschenkel amputiert,
der hatte solche Durchwürzungsstörungen,
weil er so viel geraucht hat.
Ach so.
Da habe ich dann gedacht, das ist wohl mal ein Zeichen,
dass ich mal mit dem Rauchen aufhören muss besser.
Er ist ein bisschen älter als ich.
Und ja, als wir das gehört haben,
dass Sie den Unterschenkel amputieren müssen,
das war dann schon irgendwie ein Schreck.
Ich verstehe ja.
Also, Ihr Bruder hat Raucherbein stimmt?
Ja, der hat eben generell die Blutungsstörungen
und dann war das Bein eben insbesondere betroffen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und die letzte Frage, sind Sie vollständig geimpft, Frau Maga?
Ja, klar.
Na ja, ich, was meine ich,
ich habe ja so viel Kontakt mit anderen Personen.
Ja, genau.
Ich muss wirklich geimpft sein.
Man muss sich empfinden, das stimmt.
Ich verstehe.
Und Frau Maga, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gesteilt.
So als werde Sie körperliche Untersuchung
und nach der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich Blut abnehmen.
Gegebenfalls, ja, besonders auch Ihr Ur-Untersuchung.
Mein Ur?
Ur, genau.
Manchmal, die Beschwerden können von Ouren ver...
Von den Ouren kommen?
Genau.
Aber ich kann gut hören.
Aber ich kann gar nicht gut hören.
Ja, auf jeden Fall können wir untersuchen.
Das ist einfache Untersuchung.
Und werde ich auch Ihren Brut drückmessen.
Je nach untersuchenden Ergebnissen werde ich mit Ihnen
über Beschwerden und Diagnose und Behandlung noch mal sprechen.
Okay?
Ja, alles klar.
Ja, das ist okay.
Okay, dann setzen Sie mich rüber.
Okay, Sie holen nicht ab, ne?
Ja, genau.
Gut, sehr gut.
Hat jemand Fragen?
Ich denke, Betül hat alle Fragen gesteilt.
Ich weiß nicht.
Würde ich auch so sagen.
Sofort mache ich Vorstellung oder?
Ja.
Wenn Sie mögen, können wollen, gerne, ja.
Ich kann gar nicht.
Hallo, guten Tag Frau Wererstin.
Mein Name ist Ulbis.
Ich bin Assistenz der Notaufnahme.
Und würde gerne eine neue Patientin
Vorstellung machen, Sie seitheten.
Ja, natürlich.
Klar, wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Die Patientin heißt Helmaga.
Sie ist 28 Jahre alt.
Ich bin 27,
groß und 7 kg schwer.
Frau Magas,
ich werde bei uns wegen
seit fast 1 Stunde 5 Jahren
eine Schwindelatakung haben.
Die Patientin besiegt eine Schwindelatakung
als Schwankschwindel.
Und seit 3 Jahren hat die Patientin
eine Schwindelatakung.
Deswegen war sie vor 3 Jahren beim Hausarzt,
weil die Bluthoffdruck bei ihr
diagnostiziert hat.
Und deswegen nimmt die Patientin
regelmäßig Medikamente ein.
Und ihr Bluthoffdruck ist gut eingeleitet.
Haben wir jetzt schon gemessen?
Nein, aber nach Vorstellung
kann ich messen.
Ja, okay.
Und die Patientin
gab an die Schwindelatakung,
die 7 Schwindelatakung,
da war die Ungefährheit eine Schutung,
und bewegungs-unabhängig,
unabhängig, genau.
Und in der Leste woher hat die Patientin
eine Schwindelatakung?
Nein.
Die Patientin
klagt die Übe als
Fatigue,
Verstopfung,
Ausstipation,
Schipri,
Wegen, Schitres,
Elfer,
Fragen,
Neurologische Symptome,
Fibau, Gurden,
Fernand.
Als Vorerkrankung
die Patientin
zeilert an Arterealipardonis
seit der Ayurgen.
Als Medikamente nimmt sie
Beloxo,
keine Operation ist erfolgt
bei der Patientin
und keine bekannte Allergie hat die Patientin.
Sie ist seit 5 Jahren nicht rauherin.
Vorher hat sie
den Zigaräteteknisch ungefähr 530 Jahren gerauft.
Also das Entschiebrit
ungefähr 10 Packers.
Sie hat 3-4 Flasche pro Woche
bejaht.
Die Frage nach Drohung wurde verneint.
Sie ist verheiratet, lebt ihr Mann.
Sie hat keine Kinder.
Sie ist so begleitet.
Sie hat viel Schitres bei der Arbeit.
Sie ist aus der Familie.
Sie ist in der Familie,
in der Familie zu sein.
Sie ist ein bedächtiger
Der Fatih ist vor fünf Jahren an Upperplex-Taschturben.
Der Burude leidet an Periphera, Arterie, Lefershust,
Frankheit, des Vegen,
wurde unter Schenkel amputiert.
Die Patientin ist vollständig geimpft.
Alle Anamnistischen Angaben,
deuten auf am hästen Hipotyröse.
Was wäre differentialdiagnostisch möglich?
Als differentialdiagnosekommen anämie,
also vestibuläre migraine,
und die hypertensive Entgleichung
die Tia im Betracht.
Aber sie haben sonst eigentlich keine neurologischen Ausfälle beschrieben
und sie war auch nicht irgendwie auffällig ein.
Genau, kann ich nicht mehr auf die Anamnistischen Angaben
auf die Anamnistischen Angaben beweisen.
Aber ich muss Schlimsenfeld aufschließen.
Klar, ja, ja.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit Ihrem?
Ja, so als werde ich die Patientin-Körperlische
unterzuholen und mit der Paramente.
Worauf recht sind Sie da auch merkbar bei der körperlichen Unterzulassung?
Ich werde auf die körperlichen Unterzuholen
besonders neurologische Unterzuholen durchführen.
Was zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel
Nein, Gesichtfeld untersuchen.
Genau.
Und ich werde auch
durchführen.
Und ansonsten, genau.
Augenbewegung kann ich untersuchen.
Und Sensibilität und Reflexe kürzen.
Reflexe, genau.
Reflexe auf, werde ich durchprüfen.
Ja, nach der Köperlische untersuchen,
werde ich die Bulut abnehmen.
Was lassen Sie alles untersuchen im Labor?
Bulutbild, besonders Erdresiten
und Ferritin und T3, T4, Thesa.
Warum?
Warum die letzten drei?
Um hypotöse
Bistellen oder Anzuschließen.
Ja, richtig, genau.
Und noch weitere.
Man kann auch Bulutsuka messen,
mögliche Bulutsuka Krankheit diaknosieren.
Ja, ja.
Man kann...
Was machen Sie sonst apparativ möglicherweise noch mit ihr?
Ja, ich werde auch
Ultraschades heißt durchführen.
Ja, mit welchem Gedanken?
Was wollen Sie da sehen?
Ja, also man kann
Schüttelösen
Pathologie mit Ultraschade bestimmen.
Und was kann man mit dem Ultraschade auch noch machen,
sagen wir uns, untersuchen?
Also ja, Karotis artiakaman beurteilen, genau.
Ja, genau, da kann man gucken,
ob da vielleicht eine kleine Stelle ist.
Genau, da kann man bestimmen.
Ja, super.
Okay.
Ja, wenn sich Ihre Diagnose mit der Hypothorie bestätigt,
welche Kriterien sprechen dafür?
Also, bei Hypothriöse sind T3, T4 erneutrig.
Und TSA erhört.
Ja, ich meine eigentlich mehr, welche von den beschriebenen Symptomen
würden für diese Hypothriöse sprechen.
Okay.
Schwindelataka beschrieb die Patientin
aschvankschwindel
und fershtoffsio nati patientin.
Und die Patientin für sich müde schnapp.
Diese Symptome schiepere für Hypothriöse.
Genau, ja, okay.
Und ja, ich meine, die Therapie ist in dem Fall dann ja relativ simpel.
Was machen wir dann?
Man muss alterexin, also Hormosubstition verordnen.
Und regelmäßige Blut und Terzuhung
beim Hausarzt empfehlen, diese Patienten.
Genau, genau.
Ja, dann bin ich sehr gespannt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt,
ob es tatsächlich die Schilddrüse ist
oder ob es vielleicht tatsächlich ganz stumpf eine Anämie ist.
Wobei, wenn es eine Anämie wäre,
was müssten wir dann weitermachen?
Ja, mögliche Ursachen muss ich beschrieben.
Die häufigste Ursache ist Eisenmangel-Anämie.
Wenn Eisenmangel-Anämie vorliegt,
dann muss man die Eisen-Substitution verordnen.
Ja, aber was müssten wir eigentlich dann auch noch überprüfen?
Beim Blut, meinst du?
Wenn sie tatsächlich eine ausgeprägte Anämie hat,
was muss man noch ausschließen?
Also ja, genau.
Man muss gastrointestinaler Blutung ausschließen,
weshalb der ja alteren Patienten, genau.
Man muss sie dann auch noch ein bisschen mehr nehmen
und vielleicht kann man Koloskopie durchführen.
Genau, dass man da nicht irgendwas übersieht,
dass sie da irgendwo Blut verliert.
Und die ist in einer Menopause, insofern da verliert sie nichts mehr,
aber vielleicht hat sie ja sonst irgendwo Probleme
und das müsste man dann ausstechen.
Super, ja.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden,
dass Ihr in Untersuchung rausgekommen ist.
Danke.
Und dann hoffen wir, dass es der Frau Marga bald besser geht.
Wunderbar.
Ja, danke schön.
So, ich habe jetzt heute sehr kritisch zugehört.
Ich habe mir ein paar Sachen auch geschrieben.
Ja, das ist gut.
Ja, also, Sie wissen,
Diagnostiziert heißt es, nicht Diagnosiert.
Ach so.
Diagnostiziert, fehlt noch eine Silber.
Genau.
Und dann ist mir aufgefallen,
Sie haben geschrieben, die Schwindelattacke dauert so und so lange
und bewegungsabhängig und ist unabhängig
und ist bewegungsabhängig.
Ja, stimmt.
Da fehlt das kleine Verb dazwischen.
Dann ist mir noch Untersuchung in Ergebnis.
Untersuchungsergebnis.
Ja, okay.
Also, das ist so Pillekram, aber...
Dann 1 bis 2, 3 bis 4 Flaschen pro Woche Bier.
1 bis 3 bis 4 Flaschen Bier pro Woche.
Okay.
Also, Flaschen Bier pro Woche.
Die Zeitangabe vom Hinterher.
Hab ich noch mal draufgeschrieben.
Nee, das waren die, das waren die Kleinen.
Ach, der Klassiker ist wieder gewesen.
Frau Görbis, sie stellte sich wegen.
Und vor?
Vor hat es gefehlt.
Ich hab es nicht gehört.
Sie konnte nachrufen.
Sie konnte noch mal nachhören.
Ich hab es nicht gehört.
Ja, geachtet darauf, geachtet, aber ich weiß nicht.
Also, ich hab es definitiv nicht exzitut gehört.
Ja, okay.
Das war jetzt sehr knusselig.
Ich war sehr, sehr merkgelegt.
Ja, aber aus bekannten Gründen.
Ja, und an sich fand ich das wieder eine sehr schöne.
Eine sehr schöne Anamnese und auch eine sehr gute Präsentation.
Sie haben alles in Kürze und komplett und in guter Reihenfolge,
in guter Struktur.
A gefragt und B wiedergegeben.
Für meine Begriffe machen sie sehr schöne Anamnesen.
Ich hab das auch schon mal gemacht.
Für meine Begriffe machen sie sehr schöne Anamnesen
und auch sehr schöne Berichte.
Danke schön.
Gut.
Was sagen die anderen?
Ich hoffe, die sind es mal. Ich hoffe ich.
Ja, also alle Daumen sind gedrückt, aber sowas von.